okay we have lots of news to uh start
with today
some a good some not so good and some
absolutely terrible and
we're starting there what is taking
place right now in the country of india
is almost beyond words it's a complete
humanitarian crisis as hospitals are
collapsing
under the pressure of a covid
explosion if you look at the numbers
i looked this morning and thought there
must be a mistake it looks like the
they're almost literally off the charts
and
um in fact these numbers i'm going to
show you are probably under reported
due to the poor infrastructure in much
of
india that is leading to people just
dying
in the streets that's not a figure of
speech
and uh potentially not even being
counted in the number of dead from covid
so
cases in india have surged to a pandemic
high
of 320 000 cases per day
india previously had just one peak in
mid-september they did a good job for a
long time
this new peak is more than three times
worse their previous peak
and the deaths are just as bad spiking
most recently to about
2 000 deaths per day and again
probably under reports of the real
numbers
because of the uh disconnected and rural
nature
of much of india where we we just don't
even know if these numbers are actually
the full story
now i think it's important to understand
as we
sit in the united states and look at
this that
because of india's high population india
has 1.3 almost 1.4 billion people
we have about 330 million here in the
u.s
uh we still have higher per capita case
rates and per capita death rates than
india
from the start of the pandemic the
difference of course
is that we never saw rates of growth
like this
if this continues for even two more
weeks we could have a dramatically
different story
and the level of hospital collapse that
india is experiencing
uh is different than what happened in
the united states we did get to full
icus
and we had a very brief period where we
were getting to the limit on ventilators
but what's happening with medical
facilities and supplies in india
is tragically almost unbelievable
they are out of icu beds in many places
they are out of
oxygen in many parts of the country i
saw one report
last night where they were reporting
from
the main sort of meter for the
hospital's oxygen supply it was just at
zero
people being left outside of hospitals
waiting for care
some are just dying in the streets the
images
are absolutely horrifying new delhi in
particular
which doesn't produce its own oxygen and
is dependent on
getting help from other areas to call it
critical shape doesn't even really
explain what it is that's going on there
a bunch of
deli hospitals tweeted essentially sos
messages over the weekend saying we need
oxygen supplies
at least 20 critically ill people died
on saturday
after oxygen supply was delayed they ran
out and it took a period of time before
they were
able to get more other countries are how
trying to help
but it feels like it started too late
not to be critical of people that are
helping but
we saw this coming and we fortunately
now see joe biden sending ventilators
and ppe and test kits and more
medications many other countries are
doing the same the uk
sending ventilators many countries are
doing things but arguably too late to
help
many of the people that are dying daily
at this point in time
and yes there's also some vaccination
happening there
relatively slowly some countries are
sending more vaccines
we know from looking at the numbers here
in the u.s it takes a while for the
vaccines to make a difference you start
vaccinating
after two weeks that first dose provides
85 or 80 percent protection then you
need excuse me that second dose
and that is a slow process before it
makes an impact vaccination won't solve
the current problem happening in
hospitals as we speak with
uh three people dying every two minutes
also
going in very much the wrong direction
in terms of larger countries are
to some degree not like india but the
netherlands germany and colombia
are also seeing some modest upticks
in terms of larger countries and by the
way my birth
country of argentina just a continued
disaster there with a
completely incompetent leadership
lack of transparency strict but
unenforced rules vaccine cronyism
one elected official found with vaccines
in his trunk and said oh i was bringing
them to
some hospital i mean just about
everything you can imagine
it's been happening in argentina i have
friends who just flew down vaccinated
said that uh accurate mask wearing was
at about 50
um shop owners are all wearing masks
from what you read
but you walk in and the mask is down
over the throat like
you know it's it it's a complete and
total disaster and the numbers there are
also reflecting that
so globally you know it you actually
need some nuance to see what's going on
you have
some large countries like india that are
disproportionately making the global
numbers look bad
we see a resumed case decline in the
united states
we are now about three weeks
from when israel saw cases go down 90
plus percent
it looks like we are going to start
seeing very good numbers uh
last week i said we were four weeks away
now now it looks like we are three weeks
away
and then at the same time if you look at
just the global picture you say are we
really making any progress here
we we are but we're also losing ground
in certain places
and it's going to be listen this will go
into 2022 when you consider that many
countries
won't even really be able to start
vaccinating in a serious way
until then never mind the issue of
vaccinating children we hopefully are
getting closer to that
submitted for approval on one vaccine
for pfizer has submitted for approval on
12 to 15
they did that at the beginning of april
we should be
days from the fda reviewing that and
hopefully we can expand that
to 12 plus so many different things
to be looking at some good some not so
good
and what's going on in india absolutely
terrible
which makes this next tour story
particularly
difficult to parse um the european union
will be opening to vaccinated american
travelers
at some point this summer let's talk
about that next
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't
thrilled with the idea of going into a
doctor's office right now
and thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor
on call each doctor at steady md
has a limited number of patients so they
actually have time to listen to you
you get the personal attention that you
deserve they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do perform medical
evaluations talk to you about
health concerns send prescriptions to
your home or local pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests
as an example you don't need insurance
it's only 99 bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video